Winter
Wonderland Dr Michelle Oakley is making
her list all right and checking it twice
she looks great woo look at her little
Buck she's going to find out who's
feeling all right there you go all right
reindeer and she cares for Alaska's
reindeer whether they're naughty good
boy no that's not a good way more nice
hi you're perfect oh reer kiss
[Music]
are you hungry come on there she is
there's a good girl come on I'm Lauren
at the Williams Reindeer Farm in Palmer
Alaska today um Dr Oakley's coming out
to help check on some baby reindeer for
us hey hi how's it going good how you
good to see you yeah good to see you
too this is an exciting time at the
Reindeer Farm because we have lots of
baby reindeer being born we've had 25
born so far and we're expecting 40
babies hi kids this is going to be
awesome I mean I'm getting to do
basically Santa's job I'm like you know
scoping out what's the new talent coming
up this year the new crop of baby
reindeer it's very fun to look at the
babies make sure they're healthy of
course but um just to see them running
around with their mom it's it's pretty
entertaining but there's so many of them
out here one is so blonde she's like
twoone yeah what do you call that when
you like do your hair with the lighter
at the end the Ombre ombre that's what
she is and I got a good look at
everybody okay cool no babies born last
night but a special treat was discovered
during yesterday's check a they're so
tiny hi babe Lauren has one that was
just born a little less than 24 hours
ago hi hi hi Mama so that one's
definitely need an ear tag we're going
to weigh it oh look at that fuzzy ear so
cute good boy I know sorry we want to
see how much you weigh what are our bets
here a weigh-in will confirm if this
little guy is growing as he should oh I
think more than I think 13 I'm going 135
we're going to pick him
up there 15 lb 12
oz oh my as we lift him the sling just
breaks so I mean he's in great shape
there's nothing wrong with this CF and
he's one of the bigger ones that's a big
boy that's a very big the biggest boy I
think we've had this year you did great
okay did you want to try and milk this
mama to yeah along with a newborn calf
comes the mother's nutrient packed first
milk called colostrum so the mom just
had this new baby um about 20 hours ago
so she should still be making some
colostrum possibly it kind of depends on
how much he's nursed so he probably got
some of it but we were going to take a
little bit of extra in case there's
another baby that's born that the mom
doesn't look after then we can give it
the colostrum from her I mean that
colostrum is kind of like liquid gold
because it has all the antibodies in it
it has all the kind of really important
things to help that baby fight any
infection there we go look at that you
got it yeah now it's flowing do you
think it's Clum or is it more milk it's
definitely looking milkier you know the
claustrum is really pale uh-huh so it
turns out what what we milked out of
this mama is is not colostrum um she
must have been just past the mark
because it wasn't the right color it's a
little bit wher and just more like
regular milk so that means it's up for
grabs that is good yeah it's like creamy
you're like it's super creamy yeah I
mean it tastes really good almost like
unsweetened like or not very sweet
whipped cream there is an aftertaste
there's definitely like a christmy
aftertaste
okay you're cute yes you are
[Music]
getting in shape for Christmas Eve is a
year- round job and despite the Summer
Rain Love Is in the Air for reindeer
across Alaska so today I'm headed to the
Alaska Wild Life Conservation Center
with Sierra and Maya it's nearly
breeding season in the reindeer herd and
we've got a couple members that we need
to check out let's go yep yep all right
let's go today Dr Oakley is hopefully
going to be able to castrate Zeus he was
born here at the Wildlife Center he's in
the herd with his mom we do allow
breeding but we don't allow inbreeding
so Zeus needs to be castrated where is
he which one is he we think he's this
little guy he's licking his rump right
now oh at the very back there okay so
can we walk in there yeah okay let's do
that hi
Chuckles oh grandpa oh my goodness the
reindeer are really funny they're quirky
they're all individual
oh my goodness look at this one hi hello
some are really all up in your Biz like
Chuckles with his massive rack every
year it looks crazier and crazier some
are a little bit more
skittish Caesar heck no we won't go cuz
last time I darted him L good pretty
missing she just wants to be with you
you know they're inquisitive so they
think people mean something good like
food and
fun he's the one we're going
for
hi everybody's in my
biz here we
go sorry buddy so I got a D and Zeus
right away and he kind of hopped around
it popped
out but you can see he got enough he's
got his head down he's kind of really
sedate there we
go Caesar beat it oh leave him hey look
at that punk Caesar is not helping he's
telling his buddy Zeus don't go down
like he knows we're after him I don't
need him in there tattling and getting
everybody excited moving
around get out of there Stand Down
buddy sarah sarah sarah sarah sarah
wait there we go that was a good boab
Booga he was like defending him that was
so cute there goes his
head caner come in the Cavalry we've got
Zeus down now he's looking
[Music]
good nice we're basically going to move
them right into the clinic and do the
surgery indoors Welcome to our Clinic
we'll put an IV in him we'll get him
supported we'll give him oxygen 99.6
this his temperature that's good nice
and
normal we might need a tube him he's
already kind of bloaty oh dude you're so
bloated we got to do this quick I'm
looking at him and he's like like you
can just see it looks like his belly
just getting bigger I just need to flip
him onto this side so I can deblo them
the pressure is going to make the lungs
shrink up so the lungs can't get enough
oxygen and that pressure will shut the
blood supply off so you have no oxygen
you have no blood supply and that
animal's going to go into shock just
getting all the gas out of his room in
right now the reason I have this in here
so he doesn't chew my tube off I don't
want to waste any time with this I can
feed this tube into his esophagus right
down into his stomach come on buddy
burp is he burping or is that just gas
sand I trust smell
that brutal stinky you smell that that's
that's a smell of success there he's
burping poof that is one smell of
success I know oh that feels a little
better okay let's get started now that
we've got Zeus in a good position we've
got the bloat relieved it's just time to
get to the castration that's the prize
right
there get those out of the way easy
peasy testy squeezy time them off get
him out and we'll get him right back
into the pen with his
buddies look at that cute so the first
thing you do just remove the end of this
scrotum right off of there and then I'm
going to pop these guys out
oh my now that I have them out I can
clamp them look that tie these
off there's one all right that one's
done what is
that so as I'm getting the second
testicle out there's something else
trying to come out what is that I'm
pushing it back in but it still wants to
come
out not sure what that even is so now
I'm worried there shouldn't be anything
else coming out of there does he have a
hernia that hernia oh God no oh buddy uh
I think he's got a hernia this has gone
from Easy Peasy testy squeezy to I'm
like freaking out on the inside right
now because a Heria is really serious
brick a piece of intestine is coming out
where it shouldn't be and it's likely to
strangulate and then it will die and
then the animal could die like it's
really serious okay I'm going to finish
castrating and then try and figure out
what that is what I'm going to do right
now is remove the other tesle complete
the job then I'm going to have to get
the hernia back in there which is tough
when they're bloated because more of the
intestines can start coming
out the balls are removed a lot of stuff
trying to come out that should not be
there it also feels like another ball we
just need to look at this more carefully
make sure it's in testing and get it
right back in there it looks like a ball
it looks like a ball is that even
possible are you sure that's not a
little piece of intestines no I'm not
sure because it can look like that my
stomach feels kind of T it's super TT I
know his oxygen is still at 98 Google
three bald cow like I've literally never
heard of it I don't know if that happens
or Shan McKenna actually would know
where's my phone I need a Lifeline to
Sean immediately if this is a three ball
right do this will definitely be a first
for me Dr McKenna is a Farm Service Guru
so I figured if anyone would know about
a three Bal Bowl before have seen that
it would be Sean he's going to think I'm
kidding I'm
not oh thank God McKenna you ever heard
of a three bald cow a what three bald
cow three testicles no like you got you
got three testicles well I don't know I
it keeps trying to pop out but it's a
bloated reindeer and I'm it looks like a
Ball but I think it could be a bit of
intestine but it sure looks like a ball
do you see
that yeah I do looks like a testical are
we sure
crazy no I don't know I don't know do
you see that I think it's t okay I'm
going to carefully cut in there so I
could always close that right yeah just
make a Little Neck in it a little neck
and see what comes out and I could
always put it back but if it's
intestine I'm hunting you down I'm
hunting you down buddy tell feel it it
looks too meaty to be a test it feels
meaty and it's got a stock exactly if
you cut into that tissue and it's a
hernia you've just cut into intestine
cut into intestine is really dangerous
all the bacteria and everything all
those intestinal contents are going
everywhere it's a
mess
no what no no no
no it keeps trying to pop out but it's a
bloated reindeer and I'm it looks like a
ball but I think it could be a bit of
intestine but it sure looks like a ball
if I cut into this and it turns out to
be intestinal tissue hopefully I don't
Nick the intestine itself because that
would cause a massive
infection
no what I don't know what it is because
I'm mom gasping cuz I do that why you do
that it's dude it's testicle dude it's
testical take it out I'm taking it out
this sucker's going like in the formalin
up on the trophy case holy crap that's
whack it's definitely a third testicle
testicular tissue has a certain look to
it when you open it up unbelievable and
there's nothing else in the body that
looks like that it's 100% man gooned so
you know we know that's what it is thank
you so much good job all right
bye almost done
buddy trophy testy cute we need total
family pictures with this this is just
like amazing he had
[Music]
three three Nets this is so rare I mean
come on who even would believe that
unless they saw it I sort of feel like
doing a laugh with these things and be
like check this out so what you putting
in the water Sarah what the I mean here
in
Portage we're a little different yeah I
thought Dr Oakley was full of it when
she first told me that Zeus had three
testicles cuz I've never heard of such a
thing you really did a what's that one's
name again Luna
Luna she's like I want to come on the
ride look at her come on come onun come
on
Luna
sweet what a nice I'm going to C with
him certainly one for the record books
now he's got his reversal
okay hey good morning how are you
special huh he did great I think he was
on his feet 2 minutes after we gave him
the reversals there you go good job you
standing it was a amazing success I just
can't believe that there were three
testicles in one
reindeer you set me
up I swear somehow you did this on
purpose it's 2020 man that's how it
[Music]
goes wintertime brings snow ice and
Adventure at the Reindeer Farm in Palmer
Alaska wow it's nice to be here in the
winter thanks for coming winter time at
the Reindeer Farm is actually really
great they are Arctic animals and this
time of year is when you find reindeer
typically at their healthiest and and
they love it but one member of Denise's
happy herd is having a rough season so
I've got this one that has some bow legs
and all the other reindeer pick on him a
they don't let him play the reindeer
games no a we named him Rudolph because
he has some issues and he gets picked on
he's got some bow legs but Michelle is
going to see what's causing this
that's him right there a does he look
sad oh dude you do look sad he's only
you know 7 months old he's so young and
I don't want him uncomfortable and
hurting oh it's the front legs yeah I
can see it yep he was either born with
or developed bow legs in the front so
his legs instead of being nice and
normal straight they they bow out right
at What's called the carpass which looks
like a knee and that's making it hard
for him to move around he's starting to
show some signs of lameness are you
certain that it wasn't there when he was
was a baby or not I didn't notice it
yeah right Rudolph's bow legs make it
hard for him to escape from the rest of
the herd and that's just the start of
his troubles he's been pushed into a
fence and he damaged the base of his
antlers can't really grab his ant put
around his nose real quick can you see
that CL one that yeah and he's got an
infection in his eye oh yeah you got a
blue eye what happened to you now so
he's really kind of pathetic I feel bad
for him and we really just want to get
him feeling better and see if he can get
back out with the group he's he's a bit
of a mess isn't he and no friends and no
friends on top of it except for his
mother that's good at least Mommy loves
you to get a closer look at Rudolph's
many ailments Michelle and Denise need
to First separate him from the bullies
in the
pen oh hey don't pick on him pick on him
are they mean to you the herd's
treatment of Rudolph may look harsh but
it's instinctual Behavior the ones that
are acting a bit different that aren't
moving as nice you know they can attract
the attention of predators George
George back up and so the group tends to
exclude him a bit come on
baby not Hal your broke oh I see that
Rudolph needs to be moved inside for his
exam but he's not used to being
tethered watch doesn't get out heads up
heads up hold on baby sorry my hand was
twisted there he's pulling Denise and I
all over the place okay get shut that
gate real quick can you come in or out
cuz I got to shut it so they don't get
out girl come alone wind can barely
control
them okay okay oh it's me it's me okay o
are you okay yeah hold on hold on it's
okay it's
okay sorry heads up wild
reindeer o are you okay yeah Dr Michelle
Oakley is attempting to inspect who who
sorry bu
Rudolph the reindeer's infected eye oh
my goodness with the blue eye sometimes
when they get a lot of you know ice and
wind they'll they will end up with like
a lot of trauma to the eye and then
they'll get a bluish Hue to the surface
of the cornea he's got a little David
Bowie going on I mean he's got this one
blue eye and this the brown one the
surface the cornea which should be
totally clear and smooth has some
inflamation or infection going on and
then those cells reflect the light and
it all looks blue right now I'm trying
to look to see if there's anything like
in the chamber of the eye we want to
make sure that there's nothing stuck in
there or it's not ulcerating doesn't
look like there's much in there I'm
having a hard time seeing what's going
on so what I need to do is actually put
some stain in there and see if there's
been some injury to the surface of the
eye oo creepy eye I just put some
floracing stain in there and so that
will stick to any kind of um defect in
the surface of the corneum like if
there's an ulcer or something like that
let's flush all that
away uh-oh guess what I see stain stuck
where it shouldn't be oh dear oh baby
Dar it unfortunately a bunch of the
stain won't flush away and it's stuck
right in the middle of his cornea so
that tells me that there's actually a
bit of an ulcer starting a corneal ulcer
is a sore usually caused by dryness
infection or trauma so as you can see
the stain rinsed away from everywhere
except for that one big honk thought
left untreated it could continue to grow
that can perforate into the eyeball and
and start a major infection he can
actually lose his eye it's at least into
the first couple layers to stop the
ulcer from spreading further Michelle
will inject antibiotics straight into
his eyelid all
right so I'm injecting penicillin
actually into the tissues under his eye
and so you can see that's a bubble of
penicillin and that's going to leak out
over the next two or 3 days and okay
okay we can let him up actually and that
seems to work wonders it may take up to
2 weeks for Rudolph's eye to heal
completely in the meantime to defend
himself in the pen his antlers need
attention the other issue is this antler
yeah he kept getting stuck in the fence
so that's why we cut the antlers cuz he
would reach through and then couldn't
get back out oh okay when he was stuck
he may have damaged the base of his
antler and when you get a crack in an
antler that's growing bacteria can get
in there and then it gets an infection
other reindeer owners have found when
there's pus leaking really at the the
base really below the Bas it has gone to
the brain right that's certainly a
concern if they do have an infection in
the antler even if it starts here it can
track down that infection can actually
travel down the pedicle and get you know
in the skull get actually right into the
brain infection in the brain would
likely spell death for the yelling
reindeer one by one we're getting you
fixed right up look at you sad baby
Michelle flushes the area and injects
powerful antibiotics into his
wound this is like pus that's matted
around here and so just trying to get it
all out of the way to make sure there's
no like crack down low or anything like
that sorry
love that a bit okay okay okay hey hey
are you
okay nope kick me in the face
so Rudolph um gets picked on but he is
pretty strong he is way stronger than he
seems you know now that Rudolph's eye
and andler have been treated Michelle
has one more problem to tackle those bow
legs so first thing I'm want to do is
just feel his legs making sure that it
moves normally that it can bend normally
and sometimes even lower in the joint is
contracted it'll cause the knees to bow
out so no swelling in the joint at all
really nothing obvious that I can feel
you know what I mean there are no clear
explanations for Rudolph's deformity so
Michelle turns to a trusted diagnostic
tool why don't we go ahead and get the
x-rays
done
okay you so
good look at that yeah bent you can even
see the bow in the radius in Thea there
that are kind of like you know like out
they would normally be straight right so
it's actually the bone that's bent I can
see there's a deformity in the bone it's
basically a curved shape and that's
what's causing his whole legs to to bow
out we'll never know what caused it it
could have been something that happened
during gestation it could have been
something that happened soon after when
he was trying to walk uh in any case
there's not a whole lot we can do for it
at this point that looks funny right
there mhm that looks like almost like a
little chip or something oh a closer
look reveals more bad news you can see
how things are just not lined up
properly yeah so unfortunately it does
look like he's get bits of yucky bone or
cartilage that are jumping out we're
starting to see some pretty significant
arthritis he's got some defects in his
cartilage and he's a young animal so he
can't be with this group of youngsters
that want to fight and knock him around
that he's trying to run from kind of
less movement would be would be better
for him right now but how long can you
do that I think we're going to try to
move him and his mom in with the
Grandma's you know he won't have to walk
as far for food they also have arthritis
right a
okay that sounds like a great plan the
old granny reindeer also have arthritis
and you know he just wants to be with
other reindeer but it'll be nice to put
them in a group in the old granny pan
and they can all kind of hang out
together if it becomes more Progressive
and more of a problem he can have like
daily mooic cam so okay so we could give
it to all of the grandma too you could
be do that Dr Oakley gave us some
suggestions that we can maybe offer him
to try to get through that arthritis and
see if we can at least let him get you
know a little a little more grown up and
and see how he does okay we are done
picking on you I'm so sorry you get
picked on all the time you poor baby all
right oh come on budy Rudolph's had a
really tough go of it but I love working
with these underdogs these animals that
seem like there's no hope look there's
Mommy and then with just you know a
little bit of extra attention a little
bit extra love and effort we can get
them to pull through and they're right
back on their happy way I really think
he can come around and still lead a
happy healthy life oh my goodness oh
woo yeah a TRS off with his little BS
he's happy to
[Music]
go on the road
again I'm like a chauffeur for you I
just drive you everywhere I know I'm
driving this St easy today we're going
back to the Alaska Wildlife Conservation
Center because we need to check out a
little reindeer named Fern she's the
newest member of the reindeer herd She's
a couple weeks old let's go check Fern
initially she seemed great but the last
couple days they've notice where Fern is
going up to other reindeer in the pan
and looking like she needs to nurse and
she also keeps approaching other males
who are then turning and giving her a
couple little kicks which is not good
and today she's been kind of butting at
her mom trying to get her to get up to
feed her and her mom just locks away I
don't know how much her mom cares I know
her mom's like
whatever all right you want me in there
too or no no pressure we're very
concerned now that she maybe hasn't been
getting enough to eat like is her mom
caring for her properly or not because
typically this mom has been very good
with previous calvs so we're going to
have to go in and check her out got her
got her mom doesn't care at all that's a
really bad sign baby hi baby hi
baby oh my goodness as I'm looking at
her I can see like very little
fight a she's
dehydrated let me feel your
belly she's way too flat and she's a bit
dehydrated I can tell even just tenting
her skin her skin doesn't go back that
easily her her mouth is tacky do you see
how like that is like really like
stringy I mean clearly if she's
dehydrated she hasn't eaten for a while
so she's going to be low sugar and she
also could be getting septic and have
some infection right now I think we need
to or you got a pen already ready for uh
we have a pen available we can get it
set up oh yeah she's totally dumpy it's
actually not ideal to pull a two-e old
Cal from the mom I'm taking your job do
you want to get in with us it's possible
though if we try to put her back that
the mom will totally reject her but now
I feel like we just can't wait anymore
if we don't pull her right now I think
she could die we got to
go a love you're having tough days you
little lover Fern's looking pretty sad
like she's she's really not fighting us
much she's very dehydrated I don't know
what else is wrong but we need to give
her some emergency care quickly hi
Beauty you got crusty eyes yes you do we
don't like that ooh that like a bruise
or got a little bruise it looks like at
the base of her eye I feel can you see
that she got smacked pretty hard by that
steer Fern has gotten herself up to a
few males and really got a couple
serious hits and sometimes if a calf
starts to act off a bit the mom will
just reject it at that point she's got
kind of a bulb this head which sometimes
means they're premature but she hasn't
been acting premature like she got
colostrum right away right and
everything she's got a really good
suckle her lungs sound raspy a love
whatever the causes now what we need to
do is quickly stabilize Fern so we're
going to go ahead we're going to start
an IV give her a bunch of antibiotics
and and just try to turn her around
quickly can try a little honey on her
gums M I want some too ooh Organic Raw
are you kidding me the good stuff only
the best a little bit of honey on your
gummy no do you want a little bit of
honey on your gummy nope do you want to
lick my finger oo a little bit of sugar
we kind of perk her up a bit she hasn't
been nursing as much as she needs to so
she's probably a little low glucose so
honey on the gums will help
that so I would suspect she's maybe
didn't get as much colostrum as we
thought or H like she probably got a
little in any case I think she's getting
like a whole septic infection I mean
look at her thank you grabbed her yeah
that's not how a calf should act I'll
give her a couple more injections then
we can move her over to her new digs
Fern in the situation is definitely
critical don't look there you go baby
let that do its
magic I'm glad that we're able to get
the fluids going on her we've got the
antibiotics in her um it's really just
going to be a time will'll tell
situation where they're going to have to
be monitoring her 24/7 all right all the
Boost that you need to get a good start
a better good start it's okay I really
think that with a lot of intensive care
and you know everyone doing everything
that can for that we turn her around
okay come on then but it certainly isn't
a given especially when a young animal
like this has so much going against them
you little lover a
[Music]
love I'm going to do a trial run here
the countdown to Christmas is
[Music]
on oh it caught me today Michelle is
making sure the reindeer of Palmer
Alaska are in tip toop shape
before they go to a special annual
charity event the running of the
reindeer go ahead and send
her here comes
raspberry go ahead raspberry before we
go Dr Oakley is going to help us with a
pre-race health check make sure all our
athletes are up to top health condition
let's have listen the running of the
reindeer is a a fun part of the Rond Vu
Festival in Anchorage that sounds
fabulous it's basically people running
down the streets of Anchorage through
lots of snow as reindeer chase them all
right she looks great
woo look at her little Buck here comes
another one today's goal is to pick out
21 reindeer to run the three block Mad
Dash alongside hundreds of human
competitors this is
pige perfect we're going to run the most
tame reinder the ones that are very used
to traveling who's the best around
people and who look in really good shape
and ready to run they look f fabulous
great she looks good come on
M pretty good go ahead and let her go wo
beautiful color and teeth H she still
sounds pretty raspy I'd have her sit the
bench on this one it's not like this
race is physically strenuous for them in
any way they're used to people and
they're happy to run but it is important
that they're in really good shape you
get the day off M so we're going to PL
anybody that doesn't look like they're
in their top physical form to head to
the race lungs sound good reindeer
breath smells good okay Peppa looks
great is this going to be her first race
this will be her first race mine too so
today I'm not only doing the health
checks for these guys I'm also going to
be running against them in the race
that's quite the rack I think I want
that rning up behind me a little bit of
a conflict of interest but we want to
make sure we all do well
today he'd be a good one for the race
I'd beat this one yeah so we've got our
21 Runners some rookies a lot of
veterans so now we just need to load
them up in the tra trailer and head down
to the
race at the race site the crowd's fired
up and the stars of the day are just
about ready to roll go ahead and start
unloading them doing a last check
everybody gets out of the trailer but
they look great what's this one's name
raspberry okay everybody looks ready to
go I'll see you at the other okay we'll
see you later good
luck besides being a lot of fun and a
little bit crazy the running of the
reindeer raises a ton of money over
$100,000 for kids in
need I've been wanting to do this for
years so finally get to do it we get a
bit of an advantage we get to leave
about 10 seconds early but I think
actually beating them to the other end
is going to be an act of
futility all right you all count of down
with me here we
go 4 3 2 1 round
[Music]
Dr Michelle Oakley is in the middle of a
reindeer race in Anchorage
Alaska she's attempting to outrun the
reindeer alongside hundreds of human
[Music]
competitors in this annual charity
event basically the reindeer are running
CU they want to get back to the rest of
the
group you know they're not running out
of fear they're not running out of panic
they're just like oh there's the group
let's go catch up to them so it's kind
of fun to run with them and see if you
can beat them and not too many people
can that was
[Music]
awesome this morning the reindeer work
continues at the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center well it's perfect
weather for reindeer work yeah Neville a
2-year-old reindeer isn't running at
Full Steam hi gang so who's this one uh
this is Neville Neville right he's our
steer Neville currently has his old
antlers from last year still on top of
his head while he is growing his new
antlers underneath so last year he would
have gone through an antler cycle and
they this is the first antler cycle this
is the first antler cycle c c as the
antler basically dies each year it turns
into solid hard bone and then it gets it
just through hormone Cycles it should
just naturally come off after a period
of months that didn't happen this guy
and it's still really well attached so
was he castrated as a baby or an adult
he's castrated at a year old because
he's a steer that means he has no
testicles so that means he's got no
major hormones circulating to kind of
get that antler cycle going yeah usually
reindeer steers do just fine being
castrated you know without the hormones
but every now and then I think you know
you will get something weird like this
that old antler is sticking out like
that sometimes they'll bump and break it
and that can be a big issue I'm kind of
worried because they're still so solid
in there it could either damage the base
of the pedicle that's growing or it
could even crack the skull so oh dude
why aren't you losing your antler
today's goal get the protrusion off
Neville's skull so he can grow a proper
rack like his
penmates hello
Neville how's it going is that your
brother are you the Neville Brothers
Neel is kind of looking over Chuckles
Chuckles is a big strong Bull and he
gets a ridiculously imp
I love how these feel oh those are so
warm I know so nice I feel kind of bad
that he's going to have to look at that
all season but they're buddies he'll get
over it I'm going to help you with that
odd thing you got going
there come on Chuck okay let me get some
glovies on and I'll have a feel what
we're going to do is actually remove the
old antler at least as much of it as we
can get at today a serrated wire will
quickly get the job
done the restraint is going to be really
important here cuz it won't take long
but I don't want him to poke somebody in
the eye with
that I know bud you're going to hate it
no this is too dangerous with Britney's
head there all right here let me try
something okay let's try
that good
boy that's all right bud it's okay
almost Neville feels no pain as wire
cuts through dead bone
come on bud it's okay it's all right
good boy look how handsome you are now
that you got that weird antler cut off
to get his antler cycle back on track
Neville's hormones need regulating I'm
going to be now cleaning off the back of
his ear and putting a little hormone
implant in there you're not going to
like this okay are you guys
ready now it's going to allow his antler
to to slowly continue to grow but it's
also going to eventually wear off and
shut that whole cycle down so that then
he'll shed his antlers earlier than
normal he should be on the road to to
antler correction you're just going to
have antler Envy no one's going to
compare to the lovely rock that Chuckles
has great Michelle's work today isn't
done this reindeer has head to toe
problems is there anything you wanted to
do about the hair on the leg like he
licks his legs a lot oh okay one other
thing that they've noticed with Neville
is that all four of his legs most of the
hair has been like what's called
barbered or almost chewed down it's it's
very short and even missing in some
spots so I don't know if that's just
from his obsessive licking yeah we want
to do a scrape I've seen that a lot in
other animals and it often has to do
with a M infection mites dwell just
beneath the surface of the skin Michelle
uses a DED razor blade to get to where
they hide so you can see I'm not cutting
them but I am like taking that top layer
of skin I'm trying to get at the the
follicles because that's where the mites
like to hang sometimes you do your
scrape and you don't find anything it
can be nutritional it can even just be
behavioral sometimes from stress they'll
lick and lick and lick which is one of
the hardest things to to try and
diagnose and when I get back to all the
team bonding we're doing right now this
is great I'm really actually hoping we
find mites because I know what to do
with that and we can get them feeling
better quick now it's on to the
infirmary to see if it's a slam dunk
diagnosis I'm so excited don't run with
slides in your
hand
cooies cooties coming I
hope Dr Oakley suspects Neville the
reindeer may be infested with mites oh
yeah baby I got the mother load the M
mother load so we found M I love it
especially because now I know what I can
do to help them look at that
ooh
awesome and so
creepy they are chewing and kind of
eating the skin tissue so they
definitely cause the animal to be quite
itchy now this is
like dude's got
cooties oh man that's so cool don't
don't itch
me they are contagious they can spread
to other animals on the property you
know there's two animals in there in
this pen in particular there's Chuckles
and Neville so we'll have to treat them
[Music]
both I love when I know what it is and I
know how to treat
it that treat could go beyond reindeer
oh my gosh Arnold Arnold the Moose may
be the next victim you don't have coties
too do you he's barbering his chewing at
his feet
too that's not
good good news is he's got MIT and I
mean he's loaded it's gnarly wow they're
swimming and the bad news is they both
have to be treated and I see that Arnold
is missing hair around all his feet too
should we treat him too
just since they're all in the same
neighborhood the big issue is that some
of the same folks that are working with
the Moose are going over and working
with the larger pen of reindeer you know
both pens of reindeer are sharing
halters and Lead ropes what it means is
it can transfer disease or they can
transfer like these mites so the thing
is these mites can get carried on our
clothing they can get carried they can
come in on like straw and hay oh gnarly
so what we're going to need to do is
start instituting some really good
biocurity to try and keep this might
situation in one pen and get rid of it
once and for all you need to like
probably be changing
cure Michelle shows the awcc staff how
to treat their animals with medicated
injections and this stuff stings you do
have to restrain them oh boy this
treatment is not one and done mites can
be a little stubborn they can be hard to
get rid of good boy no that's not a good
way even if I kill the mites that are
there right now they will have laid eggs
okay Kate we're good awesome oh he was a
good boy your turn we might have to do
multiple treatments to try and you know
sort of totally get rid of the life
cycle good boyy what a good boy he did
better than Chuck he was he's like the
star patient Neville should be parasite
free within the next couple weeks see
you don't have kids you haven't dealt
with lace as I say I've never had
lace try three girls with long hair
[Music]
yikes
back in Palmer Michelle has one more
followup with Rudolph the Reindeer whose
deformed legs made him an easy target
for the bullies in the herd Hi how are
you since I was here last time they've
transitioned him back to staying with
the rest of the herd he's much happier
with the big group and he's doing well
with it I mean he's still bowlegged no
surprise there I knew that was kind of a
lifelong thing but he's getting around
way better so M he's keeping up with the
other reindeer and playing with them
Rudolph's never going to lead Santa slay
but he's around to help everybody else
get ready for the big day and he's
definitely having a great life mixed in
with the herd so that's all we really
wanted hooray for Rudolph hoay for
[Music]
Rudolph and at the awcc a promising new
star is blossoming okay let's go check
Fern oh look at the beautiful
baby hi
ferie so things are looking up for Fern
we're going to come visit with you guys
you're looking kind of friendly but
we're going to go real slow she had a
really tough go for the first couple
weeks come on over here Fern she was
born to an experienced mom who' Taken
good care of other calvs but suddenly we
started noticing she was looking like
she was hungry all the time she was
laying down by herself I don't know how
much her mom cares I know her mom's like
whatever when we went in get her you
know we could tell she was very
dehydrated really malnutrition so we had
to put her on IV fluids give her glucose
give her electrolytes like we had to
really do a lot to save her it's okay
here we go and she's come around
amazingly well look at you you only
weighed like 15 lbs and now you're like
a big fat chunker the staff here is
doing a great job taking over as Fern's
mom once Fern gets bigger she will go
back in with a reindeer herd oh we just
need to kind of get her through this
baby phase see if you can run around I
want to see how she's
moving come on F come on little come on
go see her but she's probably almost
tripled her weight in just like four or
five weeks so it's incredible to see how
much progress she's made she's got the
zoies Zoomies Zoomies she's just
thriving and growing like a weed now
she's growing like a
fern come on
Fern
hi
[Music]
baby